[MUSIC PLAYING]
Earth.
Billions of years ago, it was
just a hot jumble of elements,
which over time have solidified
into the very rocks
that we stand on.
Right?
OK.
These rocks have come from
a quarry in Portland, and
they're made of limestone,
which is a
type of calcium carbonate.
Masons would use these blocks
pretty much as they are in the
construction industry.
These rocks have been formed
over millions of years from
shells like this.
So these have just collected at
the bottom of the ocean and
been compressed, and we can
actually even see some of the
shells in this rock here.
Because the shell and the rock
are made of the same chemical
substance, calcium carbonate,
they have the same chemical
properties.
So here we have some
hydrochloric acid.
And the bubbles that you see
instantly formed in here, this
is carbon dioxide gas.
There's another way we can drive
out the carbon dioxide,
and that's simply
by heating it.
So this block now has been
in the oven for 24 hours.
It was allowed to
cool overnight.
And well it looks pretty much
just the same as it did
before, but actually, it's
completely different.
its chemical structure
has now changed.
Before, we hand calcium
carbonate, and heating it up
drives out the carbon dioxide
and leaves us with calcium
oxide, or quicklime.
Because we've driven out all
of the carbon dioxide from
this rock, it's actually lost
quite a lot of its weight.
But it's also changed in
structure, and we're now going
to see why it is that you won't
find any buildings made
out of calcium oxide.
The change that takes place when
limestone is converted
into quicklime, or calcium
oxide, has been known for many
hundreds of years.
Here, in this book from 1526,
we see the process.
We see a chap with a furnace in
the background and boulders
of limestone and he's pouring
water on this.
Quicklime literally means,
living lime.
And we can see this as the water
instantly vaporises.
It's turning into steam in this
very violent reaction.
It's combining with the
quicklime, we can see it
crumbling away, blistering.
Bits of it are flying off,
popping in all directions,
generating a lot of heat,
which we can see
as the steam here.
During this process, called
slaking, the calcium oxide
reacts with the water to form
calcium hydroxide, and this is
a key component of cement.
This has been used since
Roman times and
it's still used today.
[MUSIC PLAYING]